étranger
[Musique]
merci
parce que
je n'aime pas les voitures électriques attendez ce qu'il a
été je n'aime pas Craigslist
vous comme vous avez dit que vous aimiez la personne électrique
je n'aime pas c'est mieux qu'une
Mercedes  -Benz
je ne sais pas car si j'avais un j'avais un
chargeur pour que ça marche je ne voulais pas de
cette fille tu vas être reconnaissant d'
avoir une [ __ ] de voiture oh tu vas être
content avec cet argent
vous m'avez donné pour mes 16 ans et mon
frère d'or
et mon anniversaire d'or
à certaines des descriptions de la raison pour laquelle
ils sont là, mais nous voulons d'abord faire
participer notre panel Dana Perino est co-présentatrice de
America's Newsroom